hello everyone and welcome to the other
game of the finals of the Julius bear
generation cup Arjun erigasi versus
Magnus Carlson Arjun has the white
pieces and he must win a game to bounce
back in the match Magnus won a brilliant
game in the first um uh their first
encounter in the finals uh creating uh
well uh nothing short of a brilliancy
and now Arjun has a chance to bounce
back it's quite the game let's enjoy it
and then we are going to discuss what
happened in the rest of the match so
Arjun has the white pieces and he opens
with E4 we have E5 by Magnus Knight F3
Knights the C6 and now Bishop to C4
going for the Italian game and the
Magnus plays Knight this Knight to F6
going for the two knights defense not
even allowing Arjun the chance of going
for some sort of an events Gambit with
D3 and now Bishop to C5 so the Joker
pianissimo is on the board we have C3
and the D6 nothing new here uh all been
played many many times before we have
castles and Magnus plays A5 now you
could also consider some other moves
like castles H6 or whatnot but A5 stops
B4 so it always makes sense with Bishop
to G5 H6 Bishop to H4 and now it's a
very interesting position as it has been
reached a few times for example G5 is a
known movie was played uh in 2017 in the
French team championship
lost the game to Maxima Shiela grab with
this G5 move even though there's nothing
wrong with G5 it's just very very tricky
to play in this position Queen E7 is a
non-move Peter swindler played it
against Wesley so and lost the game also
Bishop to A7 is a known move uh Hari
Krishna defeated Abdul satrov with with
Bishop to E7 at A7 but here we have
Bishop to D7 it's a very very weird move
but it serves a very very clear plan as
you'll see very soon and it is of course
as of move 8 that we have a completely
new game I keep repeating this but uh
seems like every game there's like a
completely new position already on move
8 or 9 which is uh really awesome as
players don't play like 20 moves of
known Theory they have to start thinking
right uh well in during the first 10
moves so Rook to E1 makes sense if you
ever want to push d4d for Pawn must be
protected with Bishop to A7 now so D4
does not come with an attack on the
bishop and now Knight beat the D2 so the
usual Joko piano stuff Knight is coming
to F1 then to E3 or G3 then maybe they
F5 or H5 all depending on what black
plays G5 Now by Magnus we have Bishop to
G3 and now Knight to E7 the Knight Will
nicely support this Pawn when it comes
to G6 controlling both F4 and H4 and now
Arjun wastes no time and he strikes in
the center with the D4 and okay Knights
the G6 by Magnus we have D captures and
E5 you could also consider uh like A3 or
A4 just continuing at uh you know that
with your pieces on perfect squares but
Arjun decides to trade it in the center
right away and this allows us to to see
the power of Bishop to D7 D captures D
captures Knight to F1 and now if the
bishop was on D7 obviously the Queen's
uh there would be this tension where the
Queens could get traded off but now
Magnus just plays Queen to E7 and he can
nicely Castle Queen inside the bishop
and D7 is allowing this so it's a very
very interesting approach Knight the E3
and not Magnus Castle's Queen side uh
okay the the E4 Pawn is hanging but if
you capture it now Knight the D5 attacks
the queen and you lose the piece in case
you were wondering but what about D4
Pawn so here Queen side Castles by
Magnus of course the queen now has to
move from the D1 Square so Queen to C1
and it's a very hard to decide where to
where to put the queen okay you can put
the queen on B3 but uh it's not like
Magnus really cares about the F7 Pawn if
anything he would uh appreciate if it
was gone this is covered by the bishop
so your options are maybe Queen to E2
and queen to C1 so Queen to C1 is what
Arjun plays this will prevent The Rook
from entering the game but you will uh
he has plans of moving the queen of
course from C1 at some point so Rook HD
E8 and now uh Arjun says all right my E4
Pawn is still hanging I'm just gonna
play B4 I have to open up the position I
have to start attacking as I have to
um I'll get back into the match and uh
the E4 Pawn can be captured now but it's
it's very tricky to see how because if
if you capture an E4 Knight D5 again
attacks the queen in the Knight here now
the point is Queen D6 you give up the
piece uh only temporarily and after Rook
captures any for now you play Bishop C6
and now the Knight is attacked three
times If It Moves then The Rook hangs uh
so this is how Magnus can play it but he
just closes the position A4 he says you
will not be attacking on the queen side
I will be attacking on the king side uh
so here Knight to F5 Arjun says all
right but you now by not capturing an E4
you give me a a a really awesome Square
for the Knight here Queen to f8 and now
Queen to see to adding more support here
we have knighted the F4 by Magnus and
now Rook a to D1 so the A4 Pawn is a
nice a da4 move is a nice touch but
maybe Magnus allowed Arjun too much here
and here Magnus could consider a move
like for example uh King to B8 it's uh
not just a prophylactic idea it also
serves to protect the bishop because if
Queen captures the bishop will be
hanging but Magnus just plays Bishop
captures on F5 and now not recapturing
arjune first goes for Queen captures on
A4 puts pressure on the bishop here so
Rook captures on D1 Rook captures and
now only now King the B8 we have e
captures and E5 winning back the piece
and now Magnus says Pawn to E4 with
Ponte e3 coming and that will be a
problem as the bishop controls this uh
long diagonal so here Knight to D4 Arjun
closes the diagonal and now Pawn to E3
by Magnus F captures we have Rook
captures on E3 and now Bishop to F2 and
with Bishop to F2 Arjun sets up a
beautiful beautiful mating attack but
only if Magnus Falls for it and I will
give you guys an opportunity to try and
spot it uh okay The Rook is attacked
let's say Magnus just moves The Rook
back how do you win this feel free to
pause the video and try to find what
Arjun had in mind it's actually a forced
Checkmate in five so you know have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
knights simply must come to C6 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show that's exactly what it is Knight
the C6 check although many moves are
winning here for a while you could play
a knight to the B5 you could play Bishop
to B5 it's such a such an overwhelming
position but nice to see a story Knight
the C6 is just extremely forcing and now
you don't have a move of course if the
Knight is captured then it's just a nice
Checkmate Queen captures an A7 the
bishop guards the queen king Here and
Now Queen Bishop A6 with Checkmate as
The Rook covers D7 and and uh d8 so
that's one way to do it and if you don't
want to capture that night then you
could play King to see it but then the
bishop hangs with check you have to go
back again The Rook covers these squares
and now you have to accept the Knight if
you accept it then you get checkmate in
the exact same way or if you're looking
to see it then Queen to A8 will be
checked so this was arjun's idea when he
played Bishop to F2 and but Magnus did
not fall for it he just played Queen to
E7 defends the a rook and now he doesn't
mind if Bishop captures on E3 which is
what Arjun played but that is exactly
what uh cost him the the game amongst
other things with Bishop to F1 you are
still fighting but after Bishop captures
on E3 Queen captures an E3 King to F1
also a very nice trick by Arjun uh he's
saying that if Magnus plays a weird move
then Rook E1 followed by Rook to E8 and
his game over only let's say if this
Knight moves you play some like Knight
to D5 which seems like a movie you want
to play rookie one and now you have to
give up the queen or or the queen moves
just checkmate with Rook to E8 so Magnus
plays uh Knight fourth D5 this Knight is
crucial here to guard the E8 square and
now Rook to E1 doesn't really do
anything just Queen to F or check and
that's it so here Arjun played Bishop
captures on D5 and now uh the problem is
that everything is winning for Arjun
except one move if Magnus makes it and
that move is completely winning for
Magnus so feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Magnum now while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not grabbing the
piece back or playing something like
Bishop captures on D4 as those are
winning for white and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Knight to G4 that's the move that
Magnus played and now there is nothing
more to be done here and it was in this
position on move 29 that Arjun erigasi
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is you
cannot prevent Queen to F2 Checkmate and
even if you could it's not enough you
could play something like Queen to C2
yes you got Checkmate but now Knight
captures an H2 is Checkmate as the queen
covers all of these squares uh there's
just no way to defend both threats so
Queen the the thread of Queen to F2 and
Knight captures and H2 you simply cannot
defend against this side you could maybe
you know prolong the game with some
Queen captures an A7 action I'd be five
check but there's just no way to
actually continue this you know okay if
the King goes here rookie Rook today it
might be Checkmate but the king can go
to B6 or even to B8 there's just no way
the bishop in time like whatever you do
you just get checkmated so maybe if the
bishop wasn't here okay maybe but uh you
know it's not so and no luck there so uh
Magnus wins the first game brilliantly
he wins the second game more as as an
effect of um Arjun trying to forcefully
uh win a game against Magnus which is
very very hard so Magnus takes the win
and in the third game uh the game ended
in a draw not much was happening there
at some point Magnus was winning but
Arjun never actually got a got a shot at
advancing back so Magnus only needed
three games to defeat Arjun Eric AC in
the first day of the semi-finals there
is one more day of the of the finals
there is one more day of the finals uh
so we'll see if Arjun will be able to
bounce back as you can see in the quote
above the board he Arjun says that he
was telling himself not to think too
much about the fact that he was playing
Magnuson just play as if it was any
other opponent but uh even in game one
that brilliant the G5 move that Arjun
missed that he didn't miss it he just
didn't play it he said that he founded
the move and that he was thinking about
it but that he just didn't play it uh
which which just tells you how strong
the Magnus effect is it's not just Arjun
who fell victim to the Magnus effect but
also Magnus himself as he he allowed
that with that Bishop to H4 move uh that
I also was considering uh but I mean who
would find that but as you can see once
again the Magnus effect takes no
prisoners and very very nicely done by
by magazine the first day of the finals
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and big congratulations to
those of you who uh correctly solved
both of the pause the video moments and
they were not easy I would like to thank
Maggi sokui David Kimura Don aralos Paul
sartanovic and Henry's pragons for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day